simplify 25 a to the third and that a to
the third is being raised to the third
power times b squared all of that over
5a squared b times b squared
so we can do this in multiple ways
simplify different parts what i want to
do is simplify this part right over here
a to the third power and we're raising
that to the third power so this is going
to be that from the power property of
exponents or the power rule this is
going to be the same thing as a to the 3
times 3 power so this over here let me
scroll up a little bit
is going to be equal to a to the 3 times
3 power or a to the ninth power we could
also simplify this b times b squared
over here this b times b squared that is
the same thing as b to the first power
remember b is just b to the first power
so it's b to the first power times b to
the second power so b to the first times
b to the second power is just equal to b
to the one plus two power which is equal
to b to the 3rd power and then the last
thing that we could simplify just right
off the bat just looking at at this we
have a 25 divided by 5 well that's just
going to give us 5. or we could say it's
going to give us 5
over 1 if you view it as dividing the
numerator and the denominator both by 5.
so what does our expression simplify to
we have 5
a to the ninth
a to the ninth and then we still have
this b squared here b squared all of
that over
a squared
a squared times b to the third power
times b to the third power
now we can use the quotient property of
exponents you have an a to the ninth i'm
just in a slightly different color
we have an a to the ninth over a squared
what's that going to simplify to well
that's going to be the same thing let me
write this a to the ninth over a squared
is the same thing as a to the nine minus
two which is equal to a to the seventh
power
now we also have and this will get a
little bit interesting here we have a b
squared over b to the third power so
that simplifies to
so b squared over b to the third is
equal to b to the 2 minus 3 power which
is equal to b to the negative 1 power
and we'll leave it like that right now
so this whole expression simplifies to
it simplifies to five
times
a to the seventh power because this
simplifies to a to the seventh a to the
seventh times and all these b's right
here simplified to
b to the negative one
b to the negative 1. we could leave it
like that and you know that's pretty
simple but we might not want a negative
exponent there and there we just have to
remember that b
to the negative 1 power is the same
thing as 1 over b and if we remember
that then we can rewrite this entire
expression as in the numerator we'll
have a five and we'll have a to the
seventh
five a to the seventh and then in the
denominator we'll have the b
so we're multiplying this times one over
b so that's the same thing as b to the
negative one and we are done